HAD THE SHOT.
HERE’S PETER.
REPORTER: YOU SAID THERE IS NO
OCEAN WIDE ENOUGH TO PROTECT US
FROM THE VIRUS, SO WHAT IS THE
THINKING BEHIND LETTING UNTESTED
AND UNVACCINATED MIGRANTS ACROSS
THE SOUTHERN BORDER INTO U.S.
CITIES IN RECORD NUMBERS?
>> WHAT WE ARE DOING--
WE HAVE NOT WITHDRAWN
ORDER THAT IS SOMETIMES
CRITICAL-- CRITICIZED
SAYING UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE SHOULD BE GO BACK
ACROSS THE BORDER, BUT
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN
IS A DIFFERENT STORY
BECAUSE THAT’S THE MOST
HUMANE THING TO DO IS TO
TEST THEM AND TREAT THEM
AND NOT SEND THEM BACK
ALONE.
STEVE: EXACTLY AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION THAT THE PRESIDENT DID
NOT ANSWER.
INSTEAD, HE SAID I
DIDN’T RESEND AND WHAT
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT IS
TITLE 42, WHICH MEANS
ALL THOSE PEOPLE UNDER
THE BRIDGE IT DOWN IN
TEXAS IF YOU GOT
CORONAVIRUS OR ANYTHING
WE CAN TURN YOU AROUND
BECAUSE THE CDC THIS
PAST WEEK SAID OKAY WE
ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND REINSTITUTE IT AND
KEEP IT GOING.
HE MADE IT SOUND LIKE
BECAUSE OF TITLE 42 WE
ARE TURNING EVERYONE
AROUND AND THAT IS AN
ABSOLUTE
MISREPRESENTATION OF
WHAT IS GOING ON.
LAWRENCE: IT WAS A COMPLETE
DEFLECTION BECAUSE HE KNOWS
PEOPLE ARE COMPASSIONATE ABOUT
KIDS AND WE DON’T WANT THEM
HARMED IN THE PROCESS, BUT IT’S
NOT JUST KIDS COME ACROSS THE
BORDER.
ITS FAMILIES, WILLING
AND ABLE BODY MAN COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER AND A
LOT OF THEM HAVE COVID.
THERE IS CRIME AND WHAT
WE KNOW SO FAR FROM OUR
SOURCES AND AND THE
DRONE FRUITAGE WE
CONTINUE TO SHOW EVERY
SINGLE DAY IS THAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE BEING
PROCESSED, PUT ON A BUS,
SOME GET A COURT TODAY
AND SOME DON’T EVEN GET
A COURT DATE AND EVEN
WHEN THEY GET THE COURT
DATE IT’S YEARS AWAY BUT
THEY ARE BEING RELEASED
INTO THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE NOT NOTIFYING
THE STATE OR LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES AND A LOT
OF THEM HAVE COVID.
AINSLEY: WHERE THE DEMOCRATS IN
ALL OF THIS?
IF YOUR BIGGEST CONCERN
IS COVID AND THE SPREAD
OF COVID AND WEARING
MASKS AND VACCINES WHY
AREN’T THEY OUTRAGED
ABOUT THIS?
IF THEY ALL HAVE COVID
AND THEY BRING IT INTO
THE COUNTRY WE ARE
FACING ANOTHER LOCKED
DOWN, FACING MORE
DEATHS.
STEVE: DURING HIS COMMENTS
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT SAID AND
I WANT TO SAY IT WAS THE STATE
OF VERMONT, HE SAID THEY HAVE
ONE OF THE HIGHEST VACCINATION
RATES AND THEY ONLY HAD LIKE SIX
COVID CASES IN A DAY, WHICH IS
FANTASTIC NUMBER, BUT HERE’S THE
THING, HOW MANY PEOPLE WITH
COVID IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
LETTING IN ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER YESTERDAY?
WE DON’T KNOW BECAUSE
THE BORDER PATROL
DOESN’T TEST PEOPLE AND
THEN YOU GOT THE
GETAWAYS, THEY ARE
PEOPLE THAT JUST RAISE
FOR OMAHA AND NO ONE IS
ABLE TO TRACK THEM.
AINSLEY: HERE’S THE DOUBLE
STANDARD, PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
CRITICIZING THE GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS, GOVERNOR ABBOTT, FOR THE
INCREASE IN COVID CASES AND
DESANTIS.
LAWRENCE: WHILE RELEASING THEM.
AINSLEY: AND THEY GOING TO THEIR
STATES.
LAWRENCE: THE HYPOCRISY IS
OVERWHELMING BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ISN’T DOING THEIR JOB.
THEY HAVE A OPEN BORDER
POLICY, CATCH AND
RELEASE IS BACK ON THE
BOOKS AGAIN AND THAT HAS
LED KAYLEE MCINERNEY,
ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES TO
SLAM KAMALA HARRIS.
WHERE HAS SHE BEEN, WHAT
HAS SHE DOING TO SECURE
THE BORDER?
WHAT IS SHE DOING?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SHE’S ON THE SERIOUS
ABOUT THAT TASK OF BEING
THE BORDERS ARE WHICH IS
WHY I TOOK AT 100 DAYS
TO ACTUALLY GO TO THE
BORDER AND WHEN SHE GOT
THERE, AINSLEY, SHE
STOOD UP AND SAID WE
MADE GREAT PROGRESS.
HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT
WHEN THERE’S A 21 YEAR
HIGH AND ENCOUNTERS AT
THE BORDER, RECORD HIGH
AS YOU KNOW FOR THE
MONTH OF JULY WITH
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
THIS IS A DISASTER, AND
THEN SHE LAUGHS ABOUT IT
AND SAYS WELL I HAVEN’T
BEEN TO EUROPE WHEN
ASKED ABOUT GOING TO THE
BORDER.
SHE’S FAILING AT THIS
TASK AND IT’S WHY SHE
HAS THE LOWEST APPROVAL
RATING OF ANY VICE
PRESIDENT IN THE LAST
HALF A CENTURY.
LAWRENCE: DEMOCRATS THAT HAVE
BEEN VOCAL ABOUT THIS AND HE IS
SAYING THEY NEED TO APPOINT JAY
JOHNSON TO DO THE JOB.
HE’S NOT A PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, BUT HE’S
KNOWN TO ENFORCE THE
LAWS THAT ARE ON THE
BOOKS.
HE WAS THE DEPUTY UNDER
JAY JOHNSON AND HE KNOWS
WHAT TO DO, THE
ADMINISTRATION JUST
REFUSES TO DO IT.
STEVE: ONE THING THE DAY WILL
START DOING IN NEW YORK CITY AND
IF YOU MISSED THE 6:00 O’CLOCK
HOUR, WHERE HE TALKS TO THE
PEOPLE ABOUT SOUNDS LIKE MAYOR
DE BLASIO WILL START IN A COUPLE
WEEKS THEY ARE GOING TO DEMAND--
REQUIRE IF YOU WANT TO GO
INDOORS TO A RESTAURANT OR A
THEATER OR A SPORTING EVENT OR A
MUSEUM OR ANY OF THOSE THINGS,
GYMNASIUM, YOU WILL HAVE TO
PROVE YOU HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
HERE IT’S NOT ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE YOU GET TO WEAR A
MASK IF YOU ARE UNVACCINATED.
YOU HAVE TO GET A
VACCINATION OTHERWISE
YOU WILL BE KEPT OUT
FROM INDOOR NEW YORK
CITY.